buongiorno a tutti tocca a me rompere il
ghiaccio immaginerete che è un onore ma
è anche un onere anche perché io certe
pressioni quadranti ho già fulminato 15
secondi quindi un pochino la vivo male
allora di cosa voglio parlarvi voglio
parlarvi di come l'università può
contribuire a questo tornare a crederci
che è nella natura dell'evento di oggi e
o una tesi che piano piano porterò
avanti che è quella in base alla quale
serve un nuovo punto di equilibrio a mio
avviso tra ciò che cambia per effetto
della mitica tecnologia della mitica
società moderna e ciò che permane per
come siamo fatti noi uomini è un
problema forse di ricerca di un nuovo
punto di equilibrio e proverò ad
argomentare o una prospettiva che
simpaticamente rappresento alla piccolo
principe ed è una prospettiva che si
lega a una frase che mia cara sempre
tratta evidentemente al piccolo principe
non ereditiamo la terra dei nostri avi
ce la facciamo prestare dai nostri figli
perché io cerco di pensare il più
possibile nella logica dei giovani mi fa
piacere che questo sia un evento
costruito dai giovani
ho in mente i figli i nipoti questa è la
prospettiva di cui abbiamo bisogno per
cominciare vi racconto una storia è
stata scritta nel 1951 da asimov e la
trama è questa qua nel 2157 cioè fra 40
anni
tommy trova in una soffitta un vecchio
libro che descrive le caratteristiche
del sistema scolastico del ventesimo
secolo
con grande sorpresa lui e la sua amica
marge scoprono che in quell'epoca i
bambini non erano istruiti da un
insegnante elettronico come invece
accade loro ma si recavano in gruppo in
speciali difficile scuole per essere
coinvolto in un istruzione comunitaria
in partita da insegnanti umani marge è
affascinata dall'idea che si potessero
avere insegnanti umani la bambina
ritorna poi nella stanza sotto dove
l'insegnante computer izzato e in attesa
di continuare il suo lavoro sulla
dizione delle frazioni proprie la storia
si conclude con un nostalgico pensiero
per la scuola del ventesimo secolo che
dal titolo
al racconto chissà come si divertivano
allora io mi son chiesto ho fatto una
rapida rassegna roma si divertivano mi
sembra una domanda da porsi ecco diciamo
non so se si divertivano si divertono e
non so se si divertono e forse non
abbiamo neanche modo di misurarlo più di
tanto però ho cercato di capire se c'era
un in variante tra i diversi contesti ed
in variante l'ho scoperta in una frase
di aristotele tutti gli uomini per loro
natura tendono alla conoscenza quindi
noi abbiamo dentro
cinquant'anni fa oggi speriamo anche fra
50 anni una naturale propensione ad
imparare questa è una vocazione una
sorta come dire di orientamento di fondo
che noi abbiamo lavoriamo su un terreno
positivo
la nostra voglia di imparare però subito
dopo pensato al dibattito che abbiamo
intorno
ho pensato al fatto che spesso scuola e
università sono nell'occhio del ciclone
del fatto che hanno rigidità che hanno
burocrazia che faticano a cambiare ho
pensato al fatto che di laureati in
italia ne abbiamo pochi e le statistiche
ce lo conferma ho pensato ma quanto sono
pericolosi mantra per cui vabbè diciamo
e ma le professioni tra 10 15 anni noi
non le conosciamo sono ignoti a tutti e
poi che cosa facciamo
ho pensato ai pericoli di quella che
chiamiamo l'information overload cioè il
fatto che siamo immersi in montagna di
dati e di informazioni e rischiamo di
confondere i dati e le informazioni con
la conoscenza sono due cose diverse
rischiamo di perdere anche un po nel
linguaggio qualcuno giustamente si pone
il problema se sappiamo ancora scrivere
in italiano oppure no cominciano a
diventare tutto un po buio non può
l'italiana un po di iper critico detto
serve un cambio di velocità e ha sondato
pescarlo al festival di sanremo con una
caduta di tono evidentemente tipica mia
ho preso gabani e ho detto però che
bello questo comunque vada pantarei cioè
comunque vada tutto scorre quindi noi
dobbiamo in qualche modo guardare avanti
mettiamo al centro dell'attenzione
l'università l'università è l'ambito
elettivo dove si fa ricerca e alta
formazione allora sulla ricerca poche
parole nessun posto il problema della
distanza spesso si dice
l'università è distante dalle imprese
dalla società civile sondato a prendere
una frase nel mio campo del management
dove si diceva è possibile avere un
professore di management che non ha mai
messo piede nel business
se non come cliente bene è uno stimolo
noi dobbiamo riavviare una cinghia di
trasmissione potente tra università e
sistema economico sociale
qualcosa sta succedendo ma qualcosa
ancora deve accadere
faccio un passo oltre però torno ai
sistemi formativi cioè quindi al mondo
diciamo dell'insegnamento
io credo che insegnare non sia più di
tanto una questione tecnica credo che
sia per molti tra noi una vocazione non
poteva la frase che ho citato veniva ad
harvard business review scusate ho perso
questo passaggio ma nella fretta che mi
stressa e veniva ad harvard business
review era autorevole ed era datata 2005
quindi dibattito c'è da tempo comunque
torno all'insegnare citazione interista
severgnini dice attenzione un insegnante
un minatore di talento questa è la
responsabilità che abbiamo
io credo altresì come dicevamo che
apprendere non sia più di tanto una
questione tecnica
ce lo confermava poco fa aristotele ce
lo ridice in altra forma
plutarco la mente dei nostri studenti è
un fuoco da accendere io credo che i
talenti ci siano credo altresì che i
fuochi da accendere ci siano dobbiamo
essere positivi
dobbiamo per forza guardare avanti
semmai il tema la scintilla cioè il
collegamento tra talenti e fuoco
allora mettiamo al centro
dell'attenzione qual è l'obiettivo di
questo mestiere è quello di contribuire
a costruire delle personalità delle
identità l'identità
come dire culturali identità nella
la società civile identità dalla
capacità attitudini individuali pongo
l'attenzione su quello che credo sia al
centro della questione oggi si ha sempre
più bisogno di allenare al problem
solving di immergere i giovani nel
pensiero critico di stimolare al lavoro
con altre persone di consentitemi
allenare alla fatica di trasmettere il
senso del risultato lungo non solo del
risultato breve dice ma professore e le
competenze
certo che noi diamo competenze ma io
credo che oggi lo l'asse debba essere
spostato di più sulle cose che vi ho
detto prima sugli atteggiamenti
comportamenti di attitudini non lo dice
visconti lo dicono i recruiters quando
lo incontriamo ci dicono abbiamo sempre
più bisogno di giovani che abbiano con
le caratteristiche per costruire su
quelle caratteristiche si aprono delle
praterie uso questa espressione c'è la
prateria dei modelli didattici come si
fa didattica io non butterei via il
pennarello con cui sono cresciuto ma
guarderà con attenzione anche alle aule
multimediali alla digitalizzazione le
classi c'è un premio di equilibrio io
terrei il buono di powerpoint e lo sto
usando ma starei anche attento a
provocazioni come questa il pensiero
powerpoint il programma che ci rende
stupidi c'è un rischio di
omogenizzazione di contenuti c'è una
prateria passa un'altra prateria sui
modelli di valutazione sui metodi di
valutazione forse noi abbiamo
abbandonato in alcuni ambiti
evidentemente gli esami scritti
scusate gli esami orali facciamo troppi
e siamo iscritti
forse siamo prigionieri del passo fail
forse stiamo spingendo troppo sulla
valutazione e abbiamo rallentato sulle
motivazioni sulla costruzione di quello
che porta alla valutazione
c'è un'altra enorme prateria che è la
prateria dei modelli di apprendimento
dei giovani io non sono un esperto però
credo che li dobbiamo veramente capirci
di più noi non possiamo nasconderci
dietro il fatto che loro in paiono si
dice a casa
detto a telescopio a papà google a
whatsapp cioè vabbè sono frasi di
circostanza ma è evidente che i modelli
di apprendimento dei giovani sono
diversi da quelli con cui sono cresciuto
io allora serve come dire
accanto a queste tre dimensioni
a un certo punto mi sono detto ci
sarebbero altre praterie ma poi c'è la
prateria delle praterie che è quella su
cui ho costruito un po questo intervento
che ben venga la rincorsa al cambiamento
stiamoci dietro facciamo addestramento
facciamo formazione continua di un
pochino anche sento odor di di ideologia
e non mi piace quindi ben venga il
lifelong learning benissimo perché è
questo che gira ma stiamo attenti che
per tornare a crederci e forse per
continuare a divertirci dobbiamo anche
tenere una prospettiva di lunga durata
quindi non abbandoniamo i nostri modelli
di apprendimento quelli che abbiamo
sempre avuto quelli che un po ci hanno
accompagnato ma concretamente questo
long lasting learning che cos'è ecco
quello che provo a fare che proviamo a
fare con i miei colleghi con gli
studenti eccetera è fondamentalmente due
cose su alcune siamo più avanti su
qualcun altra un pochino meno però la
prima è insistere sul valore positivo
dell'esperienza
io credo che noi dobbiamo dedicare tempo
al fare al far incontrare esperienze
troppe volte mi capita che qualcuno
associ l'esperienza con la resistenza al
cambiamento
l'esperienza è un grande valore si trova
dimensioni di saggezza in persone che
magari non sono mai state nella silicon
valley o forse perché non ci sono state
hanno una dimensione di saggezza quindi
stiamo attenti a legittimare il fare
incontrare lo sporcarsi le mani
la seconda direttrice è quella di
contaminare il più possibile la cultura
scientifica con la cultura umanistica
per anni si è lavorato un po a silos
indubbiamente concretamente io ho in
mente quando riusciremo di recuperare un
po di filosofia nei nostri insegnamenti
quelli che ho io di recuperare un po di
antropologia di ridare spazio magari
alla storia economica quindi di
costruire con un po di pazienza
una trasfusione tra la tecnica la
scienza e le discipline umanistiche
chiudo citando de gregori quindi diciamo
la stessa attorno ai livelli da cui sono
partito la storia siamo noi dice lui
tocca a noi costruirla dobbiamo
costruirla oggi non è tardi qualcuno mi
ricorda giustamente il maestro manzi non
è tardi ma non è neanche presto e
probabilmente questa prospettiva
culturale della contaminazione tra ciò
che cambia ciò che permane è una bella
sfida da seguire c'è poi un'altra
dimensione per tornare a crederci che è
un in variante che è il coraggio credo
che chi ha fatto questo evento abbia
messo del coraggio e questo è molto
bello la determinazione e quindi chiudo
citando in dialetto un mio grande
maestro di vita che mi diceva professor
mai mulà cito in italiano mai mollare e
cito da artista di strada di londra
never never give up grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]